never meet your heroes well I did
and it was awesome
The Avengers were everything I imagined
Thor Tony check it out that's once
we teamed up yeah obviously figured I'd
let you catch up
whoa just got a whole lot more
interesting let's make this quick
we're for if you can clear a path on the
bridge
[Music]
shoot not would what's your status
Thor thanks for the assist
you've got civilians trapped behind
those barricades understood stay behind
me
this should be fun
[Music]
[Music]
are you hurt for you I thank you for
good to say
[Music]
stay down help is on the way
whoa whoa Thunder God that you could
have all the fun
your turn
got admitted that was pretty impressive
cocky like that
[Music]
this coming
[Music]
quick
not over doc
hey get back here
just got confirmation a shield convoy
was hijacked this morning mr. one of
Fury's boarding three side never read
come on Tony
those are important okay whatever
pockets
Colette's fury kept all my fists back at
one place rocket to join your
destabilizes friends
yeah I know I built the damn things
have to should secure the Terrigen
crystal if that thing gets hit already
on it
day by cover all right which one of you
be movie extras shot at me hey didn't
know you were listening cities be
running away by them can't shake the
feeling we're playing catch up something
else going on here
on down there Tony oh nothing
everything's just peachy just hoping
these guys don't have
take it back they've got both doctor
[Music]
going for a ride cap someone's initiated
the security protocols the chimeras
autopilot has taken over smells like a
heist we're heading back negative
secure the bridge those weapons can't
get into the city copy that
you're up Bruce
[Music]
some of the fires on me annoying little
guy join me on my way
no I was thinking today's tip if you
want fan clubs and funnel cakes okay
Tony
we don't take them out hurry up big guy
can't take much more punishment
great I got eyes on it
Hulk bringing in the quinces no laughing
[Music]
inventions are dangerous Stark hey those
weapons were meant for the good guys is
that supposed to be a joke not the time
get your heads in the game cap what's
going on over there
not sure nut seems like the reactor is
malfunctioning I'm getting strange
readings on the monitors like we're
being pulled to a heat signal in the bay
now that's going to destroy this repeat
that crap I'm having trouble hearing
Matt do you read
all heads the chimera is under attack
evacuate the civilians
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
captain we have a problem the reactor
won't stabilize urgent molecular
structure breaking down into a gas it's
extraordinary
if you can't fix the problem and get to
safety
Shepard
if you can hear me the convoy is
transporting a highly lethal sonic
disrupter bomb on enemies intend to
detonate it within the city secure the
asset at once
no sonic bomb are you kidding me
thought the UN outlawed those years ago
let's have a look shall we
now that is an entrance
[Music]
taskmaster we need to get that detonator
that bomb goes off it could liquify
everything within a ten-mile radius
the cable Roma
from one former SHIELD agent to another
yeah
guys getting these three seismic
readings
[Music]
I'll take this
you know I was hoping to fix you
doesn't matter I have this damn it come
and get it
taking your usual note it's called
photographic reflexes
I've always wondered what it would feel
like to kill an Avenger stand one during
their cats stolen your weapons from
shield
your dance ends now must be frustrated
always one step behind you're gonna do
with it
sell it to the highest bidder I'm after
something
where is your investigation left you
you're not the brains behind this and
this smells like distraction I'm done
talking coward
what's the matter don't like surprises
Oh
I'll adapt can't learn what you can't
see
[Music]
next time guess you saw that coming huh
you think you've won what the hell are
you talking about look around Romanoff
the world will remember this day the day
their heroes
failed them
what's happening here
he's gonna lapsing
damnit laters Steve can you hear me get
the hell out of there
[Music]
screw this
some say they were set up others call
them murderers do the Avengers pose a
danger to society that was the question
Bruce that was the question well we all
lost something that day but that's not
how this story ends
you